promise you [__] an album you've been
patiently waiting out a day is finally
present I took my time with the [__] I
put my mind into every line cuz winning
side I'm trying to regret it [__] get
over hyped and all day hits ghost well
then I appreciate you man and I'm like
what are the album are you gonna keep
the creative [__] going like once again
after you gonna fall off the mat for
like four years or a planet I'll move in
Australia what'd ya get the [__] outta
your dude Australian because I love
Australia you're so going on with it
right game isn't for me man this life
isn't for me yes no mom is this is not
my thing really it's not right and I
think I'm kind of like I can I think I
get that one I get them talking about
you Mike yeah yeah like I love wrapping
in my heart and I will always be a MC
but I don't want to be a public gonna
see like that in a while maybe I'll play
a doctor drawing Trey roll I'll get the
label yeah and then ya got played mostly
only way boy you know help people I just
don't I want live a life now I have a
family one of kids one day I want to
live in a house no I'm gonna have a car
when it going family vacations I want to
do [__] like that I don't want that
being held back because I'm slaving away
to cater to other people's needs and I'm
helping their life blues help in mind
who's I day I can make someone's to make
them feel better but who is helping my
life till then I'm going to
not many people can help me they don't
because they knew that they never walked
in my shoes and I don't know what the
[__] to do sometimes I'm the only thing
home solutions for me is to get away I
been childless the yellow and watch em
and that's my [__] right if it is yes
sir yeah and I can dig a woman one is
the day of knock madness November 26
which is right around the corner
scooping it up anything else man the
documentary people go by documentary yes
out its out now so you know my phone
volume calm and support just do it and
get the album cuz you might hear you
might not get another one for a while
yeah there's no I got some coming over
travis barker oh really yeah so you want
travis gonna cook without Michael join
my AP yeah I don't know when that's
coming we can you already work on the
new boy we worked on all the beats
already here damn this is something
you've already spoken about it yeah I
spoke about before us what's up
yes what is the what is the like how did
that come from the beat of the famous
relationship Chavez Barbra hit me up on
Twitter how did believe was him at first
okay here's let yo sup man I thought
just I didn't look at the names i just
thought was really random hear him then
and I looked at I was like I saw they
said Chavez barter Justin I was a hard
drunk I was like I lost my phone in the
airport I think I was like one then I
went on Google real fast sounds like
wait let me make sure those like it
cause like Travis Parker's twitter there
was that one I was like I saw all the
other followers yet I was like oh my god
this guy just hit me up they always like
what was like I don't even do rock music
and then I hit him back I was like all
of a sudden he's like yelling I like the
shipment really thought you guys said no
bc we should get together sometime be so
i thought i was fake I'm like man he
gonna send me a mass grave I don't know
out and then but I went to studio knit
all worked out that's wussup no time in
the ministry minute sir oh yeah but then
we linked up and that's that's pretty
much went to studio vibe doubt worked on
a few tracks that day it will just be
going studi ever since I saw man looking
forward to that appreciate your time bro
Rochelle main thing when you think you
look at two hops yeah get the outrage
November 26 November 26 not madness boom
cool man i appreciate you bros yes he's
a [__] horrible wife rapper he's wack
period no way around it he is wack in
the dick in the dictionary wack it's
gonna get say this like emma davies
these to me he's the best rapper of all
time